old-timey ninja movie style logos are
hopefully not racist kid wanders into a
magical shop cliche the giant
taxidermied bird and this hate mask
would be enough to send any non movie
child running immediately this kid is a
dick to Asian aunty Curry's kids man why
don't you pay outside with your friends
agreed movie's over sometimes make fun
that's what friends do kid having ever
seen knocked up yeah yes it's real
everything here is real is that real
Jesus kid he just answered your goddamn
question listening might actually help
in your pursuit of friends sleight of
hand this good just after saying
everything here is real also a nice gift
assuming the kid wants his figure to be
a ninja what if he was hoping for a
fireman or a banker or an instructions
following construction worker turned
master builder named Emmett this is his
teacher
how does Jackie Chan have Lloyds teacher
he didn't even have Lloyd until the kid
brought him in a few minutes ago also
the scene contains no mug wine have you
ever heard a legend behind a legend of a
ninja whore no subtitles for this movie
the fucking subtitles have a registered
trademark icon after the word Ninjago I
took a screenshot and everything also
legend behind the legend
we haven't even heard the first legend
did we have to do research before we
watch this this is worse than a Marvel
movie expecting us to have watched half
a season of agents of shield before
seeing Captain America Winter Soldier
who is this kid where did you come from
does he have parents siblings I mean if
you feel the need to give me a human
live action opening to justify our
animated lego movie at least give me
something this is literally just kid
wanders into a store two minutes later
creepy guys telling a story also this is
the princess Brian at the pagemaster the
lego movie and somehow there's still 98
minutes to go be news team watching
Garmadon is volcanic lair 24 hours a day
this is
I just had a seizure and I'm not even
epileptic Jesus I need a young priest
and an old priest hey don't you dare
come out at least until our secret ninja
force that's it if they're filmed and in
downtown streets and on the fucking
Morning News do we really need to waste
syllables on the word secret how does
the news have footage from inside the
cockpit of the ninja robot and why is a
ninja piloting a robot instead of being
a ninja exactly how Power Rangers is
this thing anyway ninja and these
freeze-frame / animated character naming
screens are getting really fucking old
not all movies are Deadpool or even
Suicide Squad just stop water ninja sure
why not
let's throw an avatar the last airbender
into the ripoffs - at this point only
five minutes in mind you the flavors are
already so congealed that new
ingredients won't really make a
noticeable impact you fellas need to
inform yourselves where we're at
culturally going to go out on a limb and
say this movie will not be anywhere
close to the definition of culturally
sensitive so this seems like the pot
calling the kettle a lot of culturally
insensitive things the shop has at least
five vertically mounted TVs in its
display window this unpopular because
your dad's a villain why not just
homeschooling or not school alone I mean
how rewarding can this kid's life in
public school be even the girl with
dental headgear is mocking this dude
that's not real life and I say that as
someone who wore dental headgear like
this to school this wyldstyle 2.0
character introduction takes about five
seconds too long and it only takes about
eight seconds in total she rides a
motorcycle she's crazy got it
karma dork and the dork squad said the
male cheerleader wearing pink pom-poms
on his hands but whatever that year the
bully did in the hallway is playing on
the radio just FYI I know I know that's
the joke but come on man movie shows me
three puke then say the villains name
shots in succession and well I have
rules about that movie just earned five
sins at once
[Music]
okay this is pretty funny but also like
again to beat a dead horse
why does Lloyd even keep coming to this
school how was he this hated and taunted
but not one person who's beat him up yet
I wasn't remotely this hated but even I
got beat up in school so what happens if
they ever get assigned new lockers or
when they eventually graduate ninja T
shout out your callsign for the benefit
of the viewing audience alone as we all
clearly already know each others call
signs as long as we have these max
Lauren stop the ball
I smell foreshadowing and burning also
this hanger appears to be above ground
so why would they have to descend in the
lockers going in just go is that how
they got their name the Ninjago name if
so why did they pronounce it Ninjago
instead of Ninjago these ninjas seem to
be causing as much destruction if not
more than Garmadon screw hi Dana cool
you guys take downtown pretty good
chance no one else can hear loin but if
you're trying to keep your identity as a
secret why wouldn't why just use the
ninja code names when he's barking
orders at them okay you got a laugh out
of me movie enjoy your sin reduction
repetition equals live sex Wilhelm just
one day to retire guy has one day till
retirement mentions it and dies cliche
you know it's funny I know how to do all
those things do you yeah oh good to know
Lloyd's lack of a father comments and
Garmadon coming close to admitting to it
but always referring to something else
happens a lot and tires out very quickly
so I'm just gonna go ahead and tack on
20 cents I'm not certain we did that I
was being sarcastic
Garmadon sure seems like Lorde business
painted all black doesn't it
it's okay Lloyd nobody's parents are
perfect tell Beth the Kim Kardashian
will never truly defeat Garmadon until
you see things from a different point of
view gee thanks Oracle Yoda sensei
Dustin Hoffman rap Morpheus obi-wan and
Gandalf the cosines are not just cool
names they are the elemental powers you
were all born with like the element of
green also doesn't it seem like you
should've told us a long time ago as
opposed to some kind of new point of
view did you call his uncle because he
was just with him for some reason while
worrying about her son this woman has
poured two bowls of cereal and stacked
them on top of each other I'm even
overlooking the second clear shot of
cornflakes in this movie because the
stacked bowls is way weirder this didn't
work the last time when Garmadon wasn't
in this giant Voltron thing so why the
hell does Lloyd think it'll work this
time he throws the pesky green ninja and
its dragon into the bay instead of you
know ripping off heads and that would
prevent a rematch Michael Strahan is
easily the creepiest Lego creation for
any of these movies looks like his scalp
was removed and reattached by Hannibal
Lecter Lego shark projectiles rip off
the seagulls from Finding Nemo how did
the Sharks get in the elevator did
Garmadon shoot some in there before
we're going around to the other side of
the building knowing the people in the
office would take this route seems
pretty over-the-top for some random
opposite of random people
[Music]
his mech controlled movements are way
too fast for how slow the actual mech is
moving are you crossing your fingers
that's physically impossible like how
could I be crossing my fingers I have
these things I'm Garmadon brings up a
good point
how would Louie even know what fingers
are that shouldn't even be in the Lego
lexicon also Garmadon would be excellent
at cinemasins
okay so the ultimate weapon being a
laser pointer that does nothing then
turning out to be just a lure for a cat
who is the real weapon hilarious once in
removed but also isn't as a Lego acted
out story being told to the kid by
Jackie Chan
this isn't the kids imagination like the
first lego movie where a real world cat
playing a role might make sense I'm just
saying if there were a real world cap on
this Lego set chasing a red laser
pointer he would definitely chase this
tiny parachuting guy to the laser
pointer joke was good but those aren't
the only things that cats chase Garmadon
seems like a pretty sweet target where
he is currently why wouldn't the ninjas
regroup jumping one of the flying
contraptions and blow his ass out of the
sky
I have always tried to get Lloyd to see
that he shouldn't be ashamed of who his
father is why his father is the worst
person alive in this universe why would
you spend years trying to tell Lloyd to
accept his father's identity you're a
terrible mother her reign of terror was
stretched on and on and to all of
Ninjago is her personal litter box
this cat is not going to on the Legos
and turning on the laser pointer should
not have awakened the cat like the cat
supposedly never jumps up here and
record unless there's a laser pointer
involved this movie is never candid
before one thing it can drive me out
throw away the ultimate ultimate weapon
god damn it not sure when I just saw but
I'm ready to kill the Malaysian Prime
Minister at my next Fashion Show Stu
days are you willing to give Lloyd a
second chance not saying Lloyd didn't
let emotions get to him and whatnot he's
not exactly to blame here the entire
city knows Garmadon is going to attack
frequently no one else has ever come up
with anything better so at least Lloyd's
can trying something okay yes he's
playing welcome to the jungle but still
fluting while traveling and when you
could really make use of a non-polluting
walking stick you are all terrible
ninjas I would take care of Garmadon on
that whole but are they terrible they've
warded Garmadon plans tons of times and
woo was on vacation during the first big
battle where your little ninja ninja
nerd where your little ninja nerds
nailed it now you're stealing Batman's
jokes from your own Lego franchise
movies stealthily gone from not as good
as the other two Lego movies to
genuinely boring enlightening QuickTime
I haven't written any sins for the last
three minutes a movie because it's just
bland it's just not fun or interesting
or notable it merely is all I can
remember is we really need a ninja
master and you are not a ninja master
Lloyd's friends are dicta Lloyd and
they're also really stupid I look like
I'm making out with two people don't I
yes one of whom is apparently blowing
you kids movie villain we should be
practicing silence right now this
probably
have happened in the writers room more
often as well this is my least favorite
place I've ever been
well you chose the path taking advice of
a supervillain over that of your friend
so deal against all common sense these
idiot ninja students bring a captured
incapacitated Garmadon with them because
they believe they need a ninja master in
order to complete the quest to the
ultimate ultimate weapon which they want
to use to stop Garmadon the guy they
just made their master and already have
captured do I have that right Jesus on a
cracker
what without our max then why the hell
did you run into the middle of a battle
with undead generals you know the real
problem with this movie versus the other
two big screen Lego movies is that it
tries so very fucking hard to be funny
and it's not sure the other two were
broad and at times very on the nose but
most of those jokes hit in this one
practically none of them do a 15 million
Kelvin magma will melt your skin before
you can even feel but hey that's
gruesome
especially so for the eight-year-olds in
the audience jesus also Kelvin scale
wait what why did they let the other
ninjas live at the very least they could
have taken them as prisoner right we
just gotta figure out how to be real
ninja sounds easy
wait hey don't you have like 700
gigabytes of martial arts movies on your
harddrive
I'm not even sure how this would help
them but still convenient thought
process is so inconvenient
I guess this montage of kung-fu movies
is supposed to be funny but the idea is
literally that the robot Ninja has these
movies in his memory and they use them
to learn ninja but is he just showing
them short clips and announcing the
titles like we see or are they watching
the entire films or are they getting it
through osmosis or something like neo in
the matrix I realized this movie is
silly on purpose but it's honestly just
too damn silly make it to the ultimate
ultimate weapon that's like why do you
still need the weapon me I'll throw his
either moved on or destroyed Ninjago by
now and you've got Garmadon trapped on
the precipice up a volcano just push his
ass ever so gently into the night and be
done with it
everyone knew he couldn't throw so
giving Lloyd this job makes zero sense
contention muttering please not Jim
Croce jinxed us whatever this must have
been real exciting for all the five year
old Jim Croce fans I'm gonna teach you
how to throw yep literally pausing in
the middle of a huge battle to go play
catch and father-son bond so they can
come back and throw bricks and be
helpful to the others not sure if this
was the point or not but this entry into
the franchise feels the most like you're
just watching some kid play a lego video
game I've no arm are you
disgusted with this you already did the
foot stuck to the head joke and clearly
understand how Legos work find the arm
plug it back in move on with your life
it's not even any blood but if I ever
see that goat again he and I are gonna
have words and you could bet some of
those words are gonna have four letters
substitute movie four goat and you sum
up my feelings right now it was love at
first don't say fight don't say fight
fight god damn it people would never see
me as a hero but it doesn't have to be
this way actually it doesn't Garmadon is
right he's tried to destroy Ninjago how
many times now I'd say more like the
Washington Generals door only locks from
the outside the helicopter that stopped
working in crash now miraculously works
again you're alive he was alive when you
last saw him
Shuri was floating down a river but no
reason to assume that definitely equals
death some powers a once you cannot see
that those are the most important powers
of all but Lloyd still has no powers so
the other ninjas who now have powers
could just leave him behind as they
should and do their own thing all Lloyd
managed to do was save Garmadon everyone
wanted dead and rightfully so
[Music]
nothing says ninjas like a horrible pop
song from the fool
I don't know you man I'm not here for
you let's not do this time to Duck and
Cover the bombs coming down a radiation
shower will blow throughout your town
hold on we got it now well that's not
even a real finish no that's a goldfish
cracker just one day to retire to office
I have come here to chew bubblegum and
kick ass
it looks like my left arm except it's
the right one oh just a shoe seen it
anyway it's like this one
you know Upstate's this